hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're talking about two
different reactions dehydration
synthesis reactions and hydrolysis
reactions that are really important in
the biochemistry of a living cell before
we can talk about what those two
reactions do first we need to understand
a couple of terms first
what are monomers well monomers are
small simple molecules that are linked
together to form larger molecules these
larger molecules are known as polymers
so monomers are used to build polymers
large polymers have another name called
macromolecules
in living cells there are four types of
essential macromolecules these are
proteins lipids carbohydrates and
nucleic acids nucleic acids include both
DNA and RNA and these all play different
roles in living cells they are also
these polymers that are made up of
different types of monomers for example
proteins are made of amino acids lipids
are made of glycerol and fatty acids
carbohydrates are made from simple
sugars also called monosaccharides and
nucleic acids are made of nucleotides so
those are the different types of
monomers that are linked together to
form these polymers now this leads us to
the question how are these monomers
assembled into polymers well it is
through the dehydration synthesis
reaction
dehydration synthesis reactions look
like the one I've drawn here this and
this are generic monomers of some sort
that need to be linked together they are
linked together by a bond being formed
between the two monomers and critically
another product of the dehydration
synthesis reaction is water and that is
where the reaction gets its name not
only are you synthesizing something
synthesis you are also essentially
dehydrating the reagents dehydrating
meaning a water is being removed and
that is where the dehydration comes from
specifically you've got this hydrogen
this hydrogen and this oxygen that are
lost to form this water molecule now the
fact that a water molecule is being lost
or removed from these reactants is where
a dehydration synthesis reaction gets
its other name sometimes you hear this
kind of reaction referred to as a
condensation reaction and that's again
because of the water molecule that is
being produced now another question how
can the polymers be broken down again
into monomers if you want the polymer to
be broken down again it is through a
hydrolysis reaction
and think about what this word means
hydrolysis it's made up of hydro a
prefix that means water and lysis which
means to break so literally this means
water breaks what is water breaking well
the water molecule is breaking the bond
between monomers breaking them down
again into the two monomeric forms
rather than being in the dimer of course
dimer means two two monomers the
important thing with the dehydration
synthesis reaction is that it can be run
again and again and again and again with
more monomers being added to the end
each time so that you can get hundreds
and hundreds of monomers all linked in a
chain now one more thing to think about
we can understand why a cell will want
to use dehydration synthesis to build
polymers because of course the cell will
need to make proteins for various
functions in the cell make lipids for
the plasma membrane make carbohydrates
for energy storage make nucleic acids
for the storage and transfer of genetic
information and dehydration synthesis is
used to build all of these types of
macromolecules but why does the cell
need the reverse well sometimes it's
really critical to be able to break
these polymers down for example when a
cell no longer needs a certain protein
including a lot of enzymes to be
functional it will need to break them
down to keep them from acting on certain
things in the cell carbohydrates as well
are important energy storage molecules
those sugars are linked together and
stored in the cell but when the cell
needs
energy it wants to break those
carbohydrates down into the individual
sugars again and so any kind of process
that requires these things to be broken
down another example is with things like
mRNA mrna is carrying genetic
information from DNA to ribosomes to be
translated into protein
and when you no longer need those
proteins you need to degrade the mRNA
that's being made and that is why
hydrolysis reactions are really just as
important in a cell as the dehydration
synthesis reactions so that is it for
today on biology professor I hope you
learned a lot and thanks for watching